we're starting to get a bit of a picture
kyon for instance have a look at these
these them is nestled over here okay
four five and ten are all unbounded
I predict that all the so secret numbers
after that will also be unbounded can
you think of why what's going on what
what does this see what does it do as
you iterate as you iterate it takes you
further in a certain direction okay it
either takes you further in the negative
direction or further in the positive
drinking right as u square okay let's
think about okay now we've already got N
squared plus 1 right we're just plus
ones I think so have a very quick look
it doesn't take very long to think about
what the bow is you mean you start at
zero and then the next week sorry yeah
the next value is zero scrap was 10
right so then you iterate again what do
you get a hundred and ten and then
you'll get 1,000
now look what's happening
notice how this thing it just blew up
right
it's skyrocketed pretty fast but this is
going even fully stop right and you can
see you fight if I put in another number
a bigger number right it's just gonna do
it even faster than before hundred
twenty one plus we mounted okay now what
if there was a negative one who is
negative negative ten also because it's
gonna get squared isn't it right that
squaring thing means have a look at all
the ones that are bounded have a look at
them with me
we've got zero negative one I've got a
tip negative three on two what's another
one negative so clearly you have to be
in a kind of neighborhood that makes
sense now here's my question to you
we've said it's in the neighborhood okay
can we be a little more specific about
like where is the neighborhood stop and
fish we've already got okay what's the
smallest number I've got that's in the
neighborhood it looks like negative two
is the most negative one what's the
biggest number that I've got do I have
any positive 1 over 10 is the most
positive one isn't it right because
there's zero which is actually positive
there's nothing bigger than a tenth that
is bounded can you find anything bigger
than a tenth you already know it by the
way once you get to a half you're
already on bounded sake go right ah a
quarter can you go any further than a
quarter
it's not yes oh it's unbounded so that
means we haven't gotten very far it's
funny there's got to be somewhere
between a 10 and a quarter try number
try it you tell me I didn't have the
calculator right you tell me something
that I want to teach all these unbounded
ones okay because I'm not interested in
them anymore we've so far been trying
out all of these values in here okay the
important thing you need to get is that
all of these numbers they're all real
they're all real they're all if I swear
any of these I'll get a positive number
that's what makes a preowned on the real
world okay now I'm gonna go push on that
a little further and say this accessing
key which you used to calling the x-axis
right I'm gonna call it the real axis
okay
now ordinarily in the Cartesian plane
this axis here is y and it's just
another real axis okay
and so in some ways or you've got its
position it behaves much to say well
okay but this time I'm gonna add on that
this axis up here is the imaginary axis
we'll get onto these implications of
that in a second okay I infrared Euler
okay now where are these numbers these
numbers that have got in here okay I
think that this the largest one that we
got which was just that was a quarter
right say to you he is bounded okay so
seven over 40 right so that's that's ten
over 40 so seven over 40 is good wait
wait is it eight over forty hey
therefore it is also good alright
because that's a fear right so if I have
like if I put one over here I think a
quarter will be somewhere around yeah
okay okay now what other numbers worked
what other numbers worked well let's see
I could get all the way over to me - yes
ah I'm gonna talk about the minitor
methods in a second now what we getting
is a whole string of numbers in here
okay we haven't checked everything but
we're getting a bunch of numbers in
there Shh
now here's where it starts to get a bit
more interesting okay I'm not gonna give
you a whole rigorous explanation about
complex numbers ah I'm just gonna show
you how the arithmetic works okay
because that's actually very similar and
it's something which you would have met
very early on when you were doing
quadratics right example okay so just
write this short example underneath okay
if I gave you this so I just let me
think about the numbers
okay so have a look at this quadratic
right now let's solve it
can you factorize it can anyone
factorize it you would have to look for
a pair of numbers that added up to
negative one and multiply to one I'm
struggling a little bit so instead when
you contact on what do you do you've got
a formula for this right so you say x
equals right and then what happens what
ensues it'd be minus B which is also
minus the square root of b squared minus
4ac 2a which in this case would be okay
now be careful be very very careful
three let me let me finish writing this
out okay now this point you are used to
writing their solution okay actually if
you a careful and depending on how
carefully you're listening you were
taught to write no real solution and
some of you probably thought what's that
about like what other kind of solution
is there and the answer is there are
imaginary solutions so how am I going to
write this I'm just going to introduce
this new kind of I'm gonna say let okay
the square root of this negative number
I want to be able to work with them okay
so I'm just gonna say this let's just
call it I they're just doing it so
therefore how can i rewrite this think
about your servos and how this works
right this is x equals 1 plus or minus
the square root of now for instance
squared or 6 right when you've got
regular surds like this you can break
them apart don't you write you can write
this as 2 times 3 which actually is the
square root of 2 times the square root
of 3 right so SERDES
multiplication absurds okay
addition of so it doesn't work like this
but multiplication does so here instead
of writing the square root of negative 3
I'm gonna write the square root of 3
times the square of negative 1 which I'm
just defining as I so we don't have real
solutions I do have solutions that are
on this number line but I have solutions
that it elsewhere okay so that's this
idea that such numbers exist let's try
this guy with some simple imaginary
numbers okay let's just start with the
Train anymore let's start with mine so
I'm gonna go so this is going to be that
okay all right now hold on to your hats
because this gets a little bit weird
okay where do we stop we always start at
0 right 0 okay you're gonna square 0 and
then you're gonna add eyes so you get
okay try it again I eat irate right a
spy or an eye what do we do to this
number we square it so when you square I
you get minus 1 right negative 1
negative 1 plus 5 right whatever that is
okay just stay with me okay I'm really
interested in what happens with apt
rates and just over and over and again
okay so by the way just a bit of a bit
of trivia for you this is an imaginary
number right
this is a real number when you put them
together we call that complex
okay just a bit really
alright now let's try this this gets
tricky right because I'm gonna have well
you'll see I'm gonna ever I of minus 1
plus I what happens to this thing I
swear it
that's minus 1 plus I times minus 1 plus
I write the reason why I'm writing out
longhand 6 p.m. not used to squaring
these things okay and then I add I do I
not okay no what happens is we can
expand brackets like expand right right
okay minus 1 is 1 okay then what happens
in here I times negative 1 times
negative 1 multiplication I have to key
male items behind that's you can with
that what I okay what's going on okay
one and negative one canceled this maybe
- I cancel I just end up with mine but I
know where I goes I mapped to minus 1
plus I right so here's my sequence now
he's my dynamic sequence with I it's my
um as my sees my cluster I've started
with 0 and then I bought to buy then I
went the 1 plus I then that took me back
to I
is that - hiya son okay so do any to try
to get it yeah it's still like it's
still gonna work that cigarette we're
just going what's that all you do with
me Nevada gee I don't know okay that's
that's okay I happen to know that
there's some symmetry key which I'm
taking advantage of it will work with
photo uh we're a mile to you right I'm
gonna guess by thinking about yes so
what happened on the squareness I'm
going to square this what happens to our
square - pi - I swear is right maybe as
cancel which gives me I squared which is
negative one isn't it so then I'm at
negative one plus I know I went back
there anyway sorry guys so I've got 0
minus 1 + i- i- 1 plus 5 which is
clearly gonna go to negative